you were such uh an incredible
storyteller
as a performer uh and you also managed
to instill life in
several different characters sometimes
all at once which was unheard of
essentially you would just be able to
come out as different characters and
we'd all be 100
on board it was kind of unprecedented in
wrestling
for a while i was portraying all three
characters
and on one fateful night royal rumble
january 1998
portrayed them all in the same match
so that was can i tell you when it comes
to your children not
uh you know we say wrestling putting
over what we've done
when my youngest son hugh he started
becoming a really big fan
but he didn't accept that his dad had
been a big star
he looked at me goes dad were you ever
in the royal rumble
and i thought all right i'm going to i'm
going to get over without to show him
this video
not only was i in it i was into this
three different characters
in the same match and he looked at me
and said and you still couldn't win
like there was nothing i could do to
appease that child
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks
professional wrestler actor and
genuinely awesome guy
mick foley joins right now
oh my gosh i am so pumped to welcome
maybe in my mind the greatest guest to
yank speaks
in our history wwe legend
new york times best-selling author
activist
childhood hero of mine the one and only
mick foley milk nick
welcome to the pod i'm so excited hey
thank you andrew
man you are raising my stature in my
children's eyes
like tenfold with this uh interview one
of my uh
my my causes is trying to make parents
cooler for their own kids
because like like for whatever reason
our kids just you know
don't value anything we do uh so i
want to break down first my first
exposure to you which is that i was a
big time wrestling fan
growing up and so the first time you hit
my tv screen
was as cactus jack in wcw
yeah like turned up on on my tv and i
was like who's this guy
like what are his moves and your moves
essentially consisted
of just being more punishing and taking
more punishment
than any anyone else i was like man this
guy's like putting his body on the line
all the time um so just letting you know
that
you know i grew up a fan of yours and i
just cannot believe that
the freaking wrestling career uh you had
i mean like you're one of the all-time
greats
um can you talk about your origin story
uh you grew up in
long island not that far from where i
grew up i grew up in um you know a
suburb of new york city in westchester
but how the heck do you get started as a
pro wrestler um
you know i think you were a high school
athlete but when did you think that you
were actually going to do this for real
uh well just uh i think about my junior
year
or maybe sophomore year in high school i
really fell in love with
uh the art of pro wrestling i i
thought when i entered that it was far
more art
than it was uh sport
and then i found out in a hurry i
thought i can cover up for my lack of uh
physical attributes with a flare for the
amount actually i
did you know i was able to add that but
i remember the first time i went i
went for a training session with dominic
dinucci uh just
north of uh pittsburgh in a
beaver county pennsylvania uh so when we
hear
pennsylvania discussed as being a
battleground state i have
literally been i've wrestled more in
pennsylvania ohio and west virginia than
any of the other states
because there was no athletic commission
in ohio or west virginia so i'd say
40 of my first 50 matches took place in
those two states
but i was a college student in cortland
new york
as a sophomore when my father who was
the athletic director
at my old high school told me about an
independent show taking place
and he knew that i wanted to be a
wrestler he insisted that i
stay in college but he told the local
promoter a guy named tommy d
got to give tommy decent props that his
son was interested in wrestling
and tommy said well if he comes to the
show i'll talk to him about how he can
get started and at that point there were
only a handful of wrestling schools the
entire country you couldn't just google
wrestling schools like you could now
so i'm this tommy d uh he told me that
if i was willing to work on his ring
crew
that he would have me work out with a
seasoned veteran really respected guy
named dominic tanucci who was a
tremendous
uh amateur wrestler so uh if
the deal was if i set up the ring by
myself i would have to go
250 miles maybe it was 200 miles from
courtland new york to
new york city and then uh tommy d was
the only guy i'd ever met who had a ring
he didn't have a ring on his truck he
had it in a storage area
big yellow storage you might remember
this it was like right where brooklyn
met manhattan
and it's not big yellow anymore but it's
still a storage boat it was a hideous
looking yellow building i'd have to go
up on the eighth floor
and piece by piece take several tons of
equipment
out of storage put it in a freight
elevator bring it down
put it in a truck a rented truck drive
it to whatever venue we were in one of
the five boroughs or long island and if
i got the
ring constructed by myself before the
fans came
in he would have dominic train me so the
very first thing this dominic denucci
did we said uh okay i'm not gonna do the
italian accent
i'm not good at it but he said i might
throw it
you're giving me a forearm and i said
okay and so when i did entered i reached
back with this forearm and like
simultaneously brought my left foot way
up in the air and then
stomped my foot down as i barely even
touched him and he looked at me said
do you think that's a forearm and i
thought it was a trick question i was
like
yeah and then he wheeled me around and
i'm going to tell you he never
deliberately
injured me like he never hit me in the
collar bone the jaw or the ribs
but he proceeded to wear me out just by
pelting me with forearm after forearm
uh in the chest pectoral what would have
been pectorals had i owned
pectoral muscles and
just one by he just my body started
sinking down
turnbuckle by turnbuckle until all the
breath was out of my body and then he
looked at me said
that's wrestling and i thought this
this you know i'm in a lot of trouble
because i had no idea it was going to be
that physical
and had i not already told my college uh
housemates that i was going to be a
wrestler
repeated hundreds of times i would have
quit on the spot
and also when he finally told me uh
maybe three four months into that
training that he had some guys he was
training outside pittsburgh
if i'd had a gps or even a rand mcnally
atlas with me and seen that pittsburgh
was 350 miles away
you and i wouldn't be having this
conversation because i never would have
done it
but i loaded up my uh ford fairmont and
i took off for the first of
probably a hundred trips uh that i would
do during the course of my junior and
senior years
not a hundred but probably 60 or 70 as i
was there about three out of every four
weekends
and so while my college classmates were
going to spring break and enjoying
themselves on the weekends
i was sleeping in my car and uh you know
just
learning the trade you hit on something
important mick which is that
uh people ask me the secret of
entrepreneurship
and i tell them just tell everyone you
know you're gonna do something and then
you don't have a choice
don't keep it a secret it's good to keep
something secret especially in the day
of
uh social media i say like just keep a
diary
write down these thoughts in a diary
don't put them out there for everyone to
see
you might regret some of that stuff but
when it comes to your ambitions yeah
trumpet them so you have to live up to
them you have to live up to them it's
true
so you talked about uh how you thought
hey maybe i can cover up my lack of
athletic ability with like my flair for
the dramatic
and you went on to write several new
york times bestselling books
uh were you a creative kid were you in
plays
did you write uh like was there already
the sense that
uh you had this other strength several
books on
the bestseller list two of them hit
number one on that list so uh that's it
there we go number one new york times
bestseller thank you
yeah that's what i'm talking about at
first too but there's a life lesson to
be learned because
at one point i was two for two two books
that hit number one
and then with the best sellers i was
like five for six and now i'm like a
major leaguer in a slump my last five
books have not hit the list but
i've been really proud of them so i
think there's a lesson to be learned
that you just do your very best and
you know my son hughie when he was 10
wrote a wrote a story for
santa and we ended up self-publishing it
and uh and just distributing copies and
i told him i was every bit as proud of
that book as i was
of the book that sold you know a million
copies which was uh have a nice day
but back to what you were saying yeah i
was really creative
my mom saved my writing and when you
look at it like even as a kindergartner
i was way ahead of where other children
were
and you know sometimes i look at that i
thought there was a
one something i wrote in first grade
that seemed like it was written by a
sixth or seventh grader and i remember a
book cart
coming around the sixth graders would
come with a book card and then once a
month you were allowed to purchase a
book
and i pointed out the book and the guy
said you can't read that and i said why
because you can't even pronounce it and
he pointed to a word
s-i-o-u-x i said sue so it was a book
called
these were the sioux so i was always
interested in history
and my mom had this little uh you know
mini notebook i think there's a
technical name for it
and she would list the books that i read
and uh i
just looked through it a couple months
ago and it was almost a book a day
small books but i was i really
encouraged me
and uh without my mom reading stories to
us
and encouraged me to read and write you
know i don't think she really fostered
my creativity in that way
well it's one of the things that makes
you unique mick because
uh you were such uh an incredible
storyteller
as a performer and you also managed to
instill life in several different
characters sometimes all at once which
was unheard of essentially you would
just be able to
come out as different characters and
we'd all be 100 on board
it was kind of unprecedented in
wrestling i just looked off to my right
this is my cameo video uh compound here
and so i've got the uh the dude love
uh bandana and wig with the glasses
i've got the man a separate wig for
mankind he wouldn't have his nida hair
and so i just i i love you know becoming
those characters
and they're kind of caricatures of the
characters at this point
but it was always fun to try to take
people on a little bit of a
emotional ride that way
[Music]
[Applause]
if you've been listening to the show you
know that we've been sponsored by
helix and helix has moved outside of the
bedroom
and into your living room because they
make awesome sofas
with all form and this episode is
sponsored by all form and this sofa
i've had to sleep on this sofa at
various times because i just pass out
sometimes with watch tv
it's as comfortable as the mattress it
looks cool
and it's so easy to assemble someone as
dumb as me and is in
incompetent when it comes to building
things as myself can actually do it
it's fantastic it comes to your door
it's delivered to you
super easy assembly extremely
comfortable and you can't you physically
can't stain it maybe that's not
100 true if you really tried but i've
tried in a whole bunch of ways
chocolate food indian food i've got all
of it on this couch and it all comes out
it's amazing i freaking
love this thing if you want to find the
perfect sofa
seriously the perfect sofa check out
allform.com
it's freaking awesome and all form right
now is offering 20
off 20 off all orders for our listeners
at allform.com
i love this thing you're going to love
this thing check it out allform.com yang
[Music]
[Applause]
you hit a degree of stardom or success
in wcw
and then you had another stop in one of
like the bigger indies
and then you showed up in wwe and i
remember this as a kid you showed up as
mankind there were these vignettes
they had you uh feuding with top stars
really like i think it was undertaker
or someone pretty elevated immediately
it was undertaker yeah
yeah so i i was watching this and being
like so i'll i'll tell you what i
thought as a kid i'd be like holy [ __ ]
cactus jack is now
bad guy did wwe disputing with the
undertaker so so that you know that this
gets interesting
that must have felt like hitting the big
time as like a
wrestler coming up and you went through
a freaking grind to get there i mean you
went through a lot of indies
like a lot of wear and tear so what was
it like when you were premiering in the
wwe
uh which must have been a culmination of
a childhood dream at that point
it was pretty terrifying you know what
maybe for the sake of your
viewers i will show them what mankind
look like all right
the mankind character now this the mask
wasn't
a an amazon something you could order on
amazon it was a
leather mask and my hair was long at
that time
kind of wild and so you know and it was
this character where
i realized that by only shielding you
know by obscuring part of my face i
could make
facial expressions work for me with
sideward glances and things like that
and it
also prevented people from really seeing
deep down into my eyes which you know
they say they're the window to the soul
so i would say it was about every six
months especially because i was clearly
putting my body on the line
and when wwe came out and announced that
wrestling was entertainment not
competition a lot of people thought it
was going to be the death knell for the
business but now
especially with the success of ufc and
mma in general
had we continued to promote what we did
as being the real deal
and then people saw that you can't do an
irish whip like you've never seen an
irish whip
into the octagon or or an elbow drop or
any of those things
but by uh allowing people to appreciate
it for what it was instead of knocking
it for what it was not
people could see all right this guy's
really putting his body on the line for
our entertainment
and then there was almost this like
telltale moment usually six months in
where they would see
through or past the character and be
like
i think he's a nice guy and and so it
was hard to deny
when i was doing so many things for
people's entertainment
that i really cared about what i did and
that i think people drew the conclusion
that i was a nice guy
and that mankind with that mask andrew
would allowed me
at first i i i i disliked it immensely
to the point where even
was this a character that wwe said hey
you're going to show up and hear here's
a mask here's like
this is what happened you know uh i went
to visit mr mcmahon
and he had this um illustration of a
character
with a mask that looked more like
leonardo dicaprio in the man in the iron
mask
and what happened uh a year or so
earlier the undertaker had suffered a
fractured orbital bone
in a match and instead of just taking
time off like a normal human being would
he wanted to continue wrestling but they
needed something to protect that bone
they came up with a bunch of drawings
and one of them that was not
used but that mr mcmahon liked was the
template for what
would later become the mankind mask so
he had this idea in his head
of a map we had an idea on paper of a
mask
and jim ross who was the uh president
or executive in charge of talent
relations
had been you know steadily trumpeting me
as a potential talent but
vince mcmahon did not see me as looking
like a star
so bruce pritchard told me this story
only about six or seven years ago or had
i known it
in 1995 when i first first met with mr
mcnamara
my feelings would have been hurt he said
that you know my name came up
and then vince he slammed his hand down
on the table said
all right damn it i'll bring him in but
i'm covering up his face
and that was how i gained everything
that was how i gained my entry into wwe
but i have to believe that undertaker
got on board
and saw me he knew me from wcw in 1990
and followed my career
and felt like although i was not as tall
and not nearly as tall or big as him
that
we could have a great uh a feud based on
like psychological warfare
and so uh without the undertaker again
you and i are not having this
conversation
yeah so you have this legendary feud
with the undertaker
um with that results in this helena cell
match where you get thrown
off the top of the cage and it's a
legitimate
like three-story drop or something where
like
watching it it was 16 feet you know like
people said 40 50 pages my goodness and
it might as well have been 40 or 50 feet
when i was up there looking down
because the people genuinely looked like
ants down below i couldn't believe
uh you know i was terrified i was really
terrified and i
i told mr mcmahon that i've been up
there in the afternoon i was comfortable
but the truth is i've never gone up
there
and while i was looking down the
undertaker's music hit
and i know that every eyeball in the
place could be is going to be on him
i looked over the top oh man and andrew
like i rarely curse in real life but uh
i think in curses and all i was thinking
was
you gotta be blank and kidding me
there's no blanking way and the
entire time he was making his way to the
ring i was thinking
how can i climb down this cell
without destroying my career and i
couldn't think of how to do that so i
just stayed up there and hoped for the
best
so you wind up uh taking this incredible
bump off of the top of the cell you land
on a table
and then there is this now iconic image
of you and it seems like a tooth is
somehow like gone through your
your lip but it looks like you're
smiling
uh and and that really emblazoned itself
in the minds of a lot of wrestling fans
you're like this person
is so committed that it seems like
there's some kind of like dental surgery
on
offer and they seem to be enjoying it at
least that that was the impression
that you know what can i take you behind
the scenes as to what i was actually
playing
for uh i mean i was out of it
it was only about uh two years ago
i saw the undertaker we were doing an
appearance together
in the united kingdom and i said how did
i
manage to let you know that i thought i
could continue
because he leaned over and there's a
saying and
and in wwe and wrestling go home means
you know
this is go to the finish and he just
said go home
and under any normal circumstance i
would have thought that
i would have first of all followed
whatever the undertaker said
but on that one night i don't know
something made me feel like i was
capable of continuing
and he said i just kind of mumbled like
i'm okay i'm gonna come out
okay and so he went old school you might
know what that means the undertaker's
six foot 10
320 pounds or maybe around there he may
have been
high 200s 290 295 because we
do exaggerate a little bit he was
probably six eight to ninety
real life but a massive man and he took
me by the wrist he started walking
across the top rope and usually comes
off with a big forearm
and as i mentioned i was limited
physically but i usually really played
it up i'd be wildly thrashing
you know with my arms and body motion
and that video just shows me like just
like a big
sloth just standing there but i knocked
him off the top rope and when he
went down and sold as we say in the
trade like the uh
the cobwebs started disappearing
dissipating
and i started getting a grip on where i
was and i realized that you know what
happened he choked slammed me through
the cell
neither one of us thought that the cell
was going to give way
like it did and so i crashed through and
i was knocked unconscious
and there was a now this is where we
know medical modern science and what
we've learned about
concussions if that were to happen in
the modern day wwe they just stopped the
match
and that's the right move but
unfortunately in a weird way that was
not the move
that day um because we had this
incredibly surreal uh experience where
we're trying to piece together a match
when one of the participants is no
longer conscious
and so there was this whole world that
went on during the 42 seconds i was out
so
you're saying that uh that neither of
you
knew that the cell was going to give
i thought you were just supposed to be
at the top of that you thought it was
going to gradually tear
so that the the last thing i said to him
before we went out to the ring was
you might have to choke slam me five or
six times before this thing starts to
give and instead i went through that
thing like a knife through butter too
and the chair that i brought up on top
of that structure
followed me down hit me in the face so
that as i said i i collapsed i
i the cobwebs started to dissipate and i
was kind of like
sitting against the the bottom and
second turnbuckles
and i realized i had this big wound
underneath my lip
and i just thought to myself you know if
you could find a way to
take your tongue and stick it through
that massive wound
and wriggle it this is terrible like
even then i was like oh that's gonna
make for some captivating tv
but as it turned out with the beard and
the blood and the wound wasn't as big as
i thought you couldn't see
my tongue at all but it looked like i
was smiling
uh yeah and jim ross said look at that
he's smiling and it really became this
indelible
image it really was yeah yeah but you
know you're like concerned about the
human being's well-being
and then it looked like you were smiling
and be like i guess he's all right
you know what was the sense of things
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by hello tushy
yes y'all i know you were missing it we
are still sponsored
by bidet company and hello tushie is the
best in the business the days are if if
you've ever done it before it's a bit of
a life-changing experience and it saves
paper
it's good for the environment it's
cleaner you save money on toilet paper
guys
you need to get your head right on this
get into the bidet game and hello tushy
owns this place they are the kings of
this and their
hello tushie 3.0 bidet is
fantastic that self-cleaning technology
literally cleans itself
it's super cool and cuts your toilet
paper used by 80 pretty
freaking awesome plus 60-day risk-free
guarantee so if you don't like it
get back and a 12-month warranty so
here's the deal give the gift of a clean
butt
go to hellotushy.com get 10 off
plus free shipping this is a special
offer for our listeners at
hellotushy.com
yang for 10 percent off hellotushy.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so you did something that at the time
seemed impossible which is you take this
mankind character who you know just
seems like this menacing
uh boogeyman type and then somehow he
becomes sympathetic
and then somehow make foley the human
being starts
like emerging uh and and then these
other characters get introduced
uh you know dude love being one of them
and then you have an alter ego
um then you cactus jack so there's a
period when you're appearing as any of
the three
like one of the blues or the other ones
shows up i feel like
wwe could never have seen any of that
coming like you're this mankind
character
um how much of this was your own
creativity or input like when did
do you think that uh the wwe decided to
believe in mick foley and invest in you
because it certainly didn't seem like it
was
it was that way from day one was it
because of the hell in the cell match
and all of the
currency you gained uh from uh from that
with the fans
i think it was actually about a year
before that so i
you know uh mr mcmahon may not have been
on board immediately but
he definitely pushed that that mankind
character because
i was in the semi main event or main
event feud with the undertaker
uh for my first several months with the
company and i always
had a strong position but he never i was
always told that you could never
really become the biggest star you're
possible of being until
mr mcmahon personally becomes a fan
and so you know fate kind of intervened
in a strange way i don't maybe it was
just
circumstance but i was having these
great matches with shawn michaels who's
the champion
sean i think it may not have been great
but they were very good sean had a back
injury
and so as his opponent realizing i've
got
you know the the most valuable tool in
the company in my hands
i was making a point to make the matches
as easy as possible
for him physically while still giving
the fans
as as good a show as i could and so we
were able to have some really good
matches without putting him in peril
i would play up the character i would
use these two fingers oh they were a
weapon i would go to the throat and sean
was so sympathetic
that i didn't need to be throwing him
around he would go an entire match
without
you know what we call a bump and we were
really having these good matches
and sean said to me goes don't take this
the wrong way but is this how you always
imagined yourself
because the mankind character like you
stated in 96
it was really dark uh and i i laughed i
said no
i wanted to be you he kind of looked and
puzzled i said i mean not shawn michaels
but i
i told him about this character i
created dude love when i was 18 years
old
who was everything that i was not he was
confident he was cool
the women loved him and when bruce
prichard was uh
vince mcmahon's right-hand man he
overheard the conversation
and he went to vince and he said mick
foley has this character he created and
he's got
video of it and so vince uh he wanted to
do he wanted people to understand
me not just the character like to his
credit
uh he understood that the real life
story i had was more interesting than
the fictional
portrait we kind of created together
painted together as mankind
so he said we want to do an interview
with jim you and jim ross
we wanted to be as yourself and i said
vince i've got a lot of
work tied up in this character like it
probably terrified you a little bit when
you were a child right
i said i don't want to just give in to
that and explain that it was all a
character and he said well mick we
really want people to know you i said
what if i give 100 honest answers but i
do them in the character of mankind
and he said do you think you can do that
oh yeah i know i can for everything i
lacked
physically you know i made up for with a
self-confidence that could
border on delusion but i think i was
always on the right side of that fine
line
and that night you know what unfolded
was just really special
at a certain point they had to change
tapes it was dark in that studio in
stamford i didn't even know vince was
there that night and then out of the
darkness i heard a voice that said
this is outstanding and from that point
on he really believed in the character
he want he called me up at about 6 30
a.m because he barely
he barely sleeps i was living on the
florida panhandle at that time and he
was like hey belle
how'd you like to be dude love and i
said just once he goes from now on and
so he wanted people to he wanted me to
live out that dream
then he found out how important the
cactus jack character had been
allowed that to come to life in madison
square garden which was the that was
september of 97
that was the arena i grew up hitchhiking
to and taking trains to and so
he allowed these things to happen to
where i could on that one night we'd
spent uh
12 hours you know that afternoon against
a green screen
creating this memorable conversation
between all three of the characters
so uh we introduced cactus jack who
ended up getting a phenomenal reaction
in madison square garden and so for a
while i was portraying all three
characters
and on one fateful night royal rumble
january 1998
portrayed them all in the same match
so that was can i tell you when it comes
to your children not
uh you know we say been wrestling
putting over what we've done
when my youngest son hugh somewhere
around 2006
2007 when he started to become a really
big 2008 he started becoming a really
big fan but he didn't accept that his
dad had been a big star
he looked at me goes dad were you ever
in the royal rumble
and i thought all right i'm going to i'm
going to get over with you i'm going to
show him this video
not only was i in it i was into this
three different characters
in the same match and he looked at me
and said and you still couldn't win
like there was nothing i could do to
appease that child
well i remember that uh event uh
and during this run i have to say like
you transcended a lot of what else was
going on
um and it seemed like it really was your
humanity or essence
actually coming through like people
rooted for you does mick foley the human
being
people felt like they knew you in a
different way than they knew other
performances
and build that connection with you like
i think it's one reason why your
popularity and likability just
span decades and will stand the test of
time i think you're
either the or one of the most beloved
figures uh in wrestling because everyone
just feels
like they know you as a person uh and
now i know you a little bit as a person
and you know you're the same person that
you know like
you know you're i'm gonna go out on a
limb and say dwayne johnson
may be a little bit more beloved
universally uh
but there's nothing wrong with being
second to dwayne johnson which brings me
to a question i i you know i i
raised with uh some other performers
because i'm just going to throw this out
to you
can you and i have talked about politics
somewhat we bonded when we were trying
to swing
uh the senate races in georgia which we
won so that was
the best thing ever um but but what i
was saying to folks
uh as a wrestling fan growing up
and a fan of comedy that there is and
you've been in a comedian as well i mean
you're like a creative and a writer and
performer
uh that there are real overlaps
between pro wrestling
comedy and politics that they
they really do touch on a lot of the
same things and what i say to folks is
when i was running for president
i would show up to the bowling alley or
the restaurant
in iowa and just talk to people about
you know my hopes and vision for the
country
and then you come back you know a little
while later and you hope that the
crowd's a little bigger
and you're just like going around in
nooks and crannies
and i feel like a lot of comedians can
relate to that and a lot of
wrestlers could relate to that because
you've traveled this country
hundreds of times you've seen towns that
you know it's like
you know towns in a way that uh others
don't um and so i posed this question to
other people
if there was a pro wrestler
who would make it in politics you would
be very high on my list honestly
um but but who though you know you might
be too
uh wise to actually run for office but
but like um who do you think
of the performers you know uh would make
it in either
politics or comedy based upon what
you've seen and you should know i
channeled pro wrestling sometimes
uh when i i was running for office where
sometimes if you see
um some of some of my rallies like i
actually have some kind of
like pro wrestler affectations
i did not know that but that's nice to
know
uh first of all i want to mention that
um
a usc fighter leslie smith she was one
of the biggest
proponents of the yang gang and she and
i bonded love
leslie yeah right leslie nearly lost her
ear
in a ufc fight and i reached out to her
and i'm part of that uh
there's left here right here lost part
of that
27 years ago in munich germany and i
said like
leslie it gets better and then the story
made like
international sporting news and she and
i bonded over that experience
to the point where i said hey let me
talk to you on the phone because
sometimes you need a good old-fashioned
phone call she was really down about
having lost the match i said hold on
wait a second let me call you
i was trying to tell her about those
incredible images
that are in people's minds uh you know
when i grew up
there was a picture of a court a giant
of new york giants quarterback y.a
tiddly and this little
streak of blood going down is uh
a mostly bald head
and it was so iconic he's there on an
empty field on his knees
holding his helmet and i said leslie
people aren't going to remember who
won they're only going to remember that
you continued
fighting despite the fact that your ear
was nearly lost and my son mickey
mickey is my son on the autism spectrum
you and i just had a chance to mention
that
we have something in common mickey goes
are you talking about that
the woman who almost lost her ear i said
yeah i said what did she do
i knew darn well she didn't quit did she
just quit he goes no
she wanted to keep fighting and i said
you see this is a child i can't remember
how old mickey was at the time i was
like all he remembers
is that you were nearly injured and you
you kept on going so i know why
that was kind of like a little segway
there but when but she's a huge fan
leslie also is an aspiring comedian too
i mean
she came to my show in the bay area and
leslie's great if she wants to do it
hey i'm going to hit the road again i'm
making up but this is not meant as a
cheap way to get people to check please
please people want to know but i'm
hitting the midwest
i'm doing the dates that were cancelled
because of the pandemic so i'm uh
hitting
iowa michigan indiana illinois
uh i think those four states and people
go to realmickfoley.com
and check out my events and it's a
one-man show where i
you know it's largely a wrestling
related show
uh i did it's nice to make people think
but i don't do current events i don't do
politics because i'm there to make
people smile and uh
send everybody home happy not to get
them you know i i willingly
lost a pretty you know i
lost some people along the way because i
felt like it was worth speaking out
against what i thought was
you know the country going down a really
bad road
potentially with uh president trump and
i'm glad i did that
but when i do my shows that's not
something that i want to do that makes
perfect sense
totally yeah yeah because it is a torn
electorate
and it's really unfortunate yeah and you
just want to bring people together uh
you know i get it i mean
uh comedy i think is really unifying uh
you know i think there are different
uh ways that people uh can experience
life together and when you travel the
country the way you have too it's like
you see people more as people and not
um you know different political
ideologies
at least that was my experience on the
road as well
i did one thing which teased being
political
but clearly was not and i
sensed the crowd that night i said you
want to know
that's funny like you like touched a
nerve and you're like on it and right
away it was like whoa that's like the
third rail
and it was something i didn't write it
out i'm convinced that there's something
there but i said in this world where you
don't know who you can trust
i'll tell you he can trust you can trust
joe
and all of a sudden like half the crowd
tenses up with booze and i said hey i
don't know him that well
but i saw him he was carrying a handgun
i just happened to say hey joe where are
you going with that gun in your hand
and he said i'm going down to shoot my
old lady i started messing around with
another man and i jumped out like
he didn't have to tell me all that you
know like this is a guy
he didn't even tell me geographically
where he was going and then i tried to
say that would be like saying
hey colonel mustard where are you going
with that candlestick in your hand you
know i'm going down to the conservator
and there was something there but it was
so obvious to me
that people were gonna you know the nice
thing one of the great things about
comedy it's like tension and release the
same way that
professional wrestling is you want to
build up a certain amount of tension
wrestling you do it with a heat segment
bad guy get some heat on the good guy
the release is
you know the uh the big comeback
sometimes you tease a comeback you know
what's
known as a false hope spot and you try
to in that way take people on emotional
rollercoaster
and it's the same way you know when
you're telling stories you want there to
be some tension
but i was like wow the amount of tension
that
one little tease of politics created
wasn't worth that very minimal
like it's like yeah but enough people
who do it
you know well and i went to one show a
friend of mine thought that i was going
to be offended because he was you know a
comic with
i guess you could say you know kind of
conservative he was teasing
uh you know progressive values but he
did it in a way his name is jimmy
schubert
he did it in a way that was just like
side-splittingly funny
so i think there are ways of poking fun
and things that we can all agree
are silly or overdone and then you
exaggerate something and
but it takes a real pro to do it well
so uh there was a subject uh i was asked
about and i said
about covering comedy and i said it's
kind of like trying to hit a slider low
and away
it's possible but the odds are you're
just going to look
foolish and strike out so it's better
just to lay off that pitch
and so i learned by sticking to things
you know uh that are universal
that most people can find a little bit
of themselves in when i do my stories
that i do send people home uh happy and
that really became a concern of mine you
know when the
economy took that big hit in 2007 2008 i
thought
people are really they're making a
decision to put their money down
at an investment in their time some of
them have to get a babysitter
by the time they buy a few drinks and
dinners you know they've got a couple
hundred dollars invested
i i want everyone to go home happy and
so that's why i could never be a
politician because
you know just knowing you're going to
lose 50 percent of the people or for
i mean you know joe biden 49 or whatever
it is
yeah and it's like they viscerally hate
you
they don't just disagree with you some
people just viscerally hate you because
you don't stand for the same things they
do
well hopefully we can do something over
the next number of months and years to
try and
uh break up the polarization i'm very
passionate about that
because i've been around enough of the
country to know that uh
there are wonderful people of every
political background alignment
and uh folks that want to
pit us against each other ideologically
you know i i just don't think that's
the right way forward
[Music]
[Applause]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by better help guys i've been
doing better help
i have this counselor sarah she's
freaking awesome
i do it once a week easy to set up
i started as soon as i signed up it was
freaking it's like my steam valve i just
pull like release some steam
and so for you whether you're struggling
with depression stress anxiety
anger family conflicts whatever is in
your mind it is important to get your
mind right
important to focus on your mental health
and better help is freaking awesome
it's secure it's confidential it is
professional counseling done securely
online so i want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener
you're going to get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people
who've taken charge of their mental
health
again that's better help
betterhelphelp.com
yang don't be stupid make sure you do
this think about your mental health
betterhelp.com
you were a singular figure in part
because you had such this incredible
creative output um you must have felt a
lot of pressure when you wrote that
first book
uh did you imagine it going to number
one on the new york times bestseller
list
like you know like what was that process
like well what happened was
wwe had landed a publishing contract
with
regan books judith regan had her own
imprint with
simon schuster and the four books
were me dwayne johnson
steve austin oh man maybe there were
only three i thought there were four
and steve and dwayne were they were much
bigger stars than i was i always thought
i was chosen to go first just
test it out you're like the crash test
dummy let's see
exactly if there was going to be a
failure was going to be me
and uh i had a writer who's really
respected sports writer but he hadn't
been involved in wrestling for a long
time
and uh and he was writing it as if it
was you know what we
call wrestling kayfabe like it was 100
real i just thought
we're really uh we're really insulting
people's intelligence here and so i
would find
things and i would say to him okay what
if we did this differently
like i said okay at this point you said
when i was 10 i wanted to be like the
fonz
and he said well i said well don't we
need to explain who he was he said well
who was he
so i said how about this how about you
say when i was 10 i wanted to be like
the fonz
comma arthur fonzarelli from tv's happy
days
there's no doubt about it the fonz was
the man he could fix a
broken jukebox with a slap of his palm
and the fawns had women lined up down
the hall
okay that's good and he's writing it
down by hand i said one of the small
pleasures of my life
is seeing my own children watching the
fawns on nick at night and thinking he's
every bit as cool
as i did okay michael that's good i said
and then put
hay with like four why's at the end he
said i can't do that
i said why not he said it's not a
complete sentence so i asked edge and
christian you know two wrestlers you
would know
and what did the fonz used to say and
they said hey
he said okay i'll do it but i don't
agree with it and so the more
suggestions i gave him the more i
thought
i like the way i phrase things more than
he does
and so the strange thing about that book
andrew is i actually started it
i started the second half first i
thought all right we'll do the first
half that he wrote
i'll do the second half and then within
a few days of writing
i thought i'm going to do this whole
thing so i they wanted 60 000 words i
turned in almost
200 000 words and i was so heavy on
words that the first
chapter of the first the first words the
first chapter says
i turned 18 in the summer of 1983 like
i didn't have time to talk about my
childhood
and uh um i know that uh
there were people in the book world that
thought there's no way wrestling fans
are going to read uh
it was i think 180 000 words and judith
regan was a
real big proponent she liked like the
segways that would go off and the
tangents i went off on
and she recognized what she thought was
a pretty unique writing style
very conversational and so i didn't feel
what i felt pressure was to have a book
that i could be proud of
i knew my career was coming to an end
and i just wanted to be proud of my name
on something
i didn't feel pressured to hit the new
york times list because i didn't think
that was
a possibility in my introduction that
if i i hoped it hit the best time best
seller list because i know that would
make my mother proud
and for the rest of my career i could go
on as mick foley
wrestler slash best-selling author and
then in its first week it hit number
three
right below uh tuesdays with maury and
something else
uh uh i think it was uh
the guy who wrote uh angela's ashes he
had a follow-up called tiz
second week i hit number one uh
dwayne's book came out like a month
later and
at one and his went on to be number one
but at one point i think he was number
one
and i was number three so only tuesdays
with maury prevented a
clean wrestling sweep and it was just he
really meant a lot to me
because people were not only enjoying it
but they knew that i had written it
myself which was
extremely rare at that time the thought
that uh sure i mean heck you know you
uh it's a very unique capacity mick i
will say too that
um i uh write my own books
in part because i don't know any other
way to do it and i feel like people
can tell the difference so the fact that
you've had such a prolific
writing career now published i want to
say 10 books
both children's and autobiographical
and fiction um but a lot of it must have
been born of the fact it's like wow
you know like i hit a home run first
time at bat then you could just be like
oh
i can do this i did yeah and you know
what it did
i i alluded to some of the books i did
that were not big successes
um and that's okay you know you learn as
much
about yourself probably more with
failures and that's certainly
the case in wrestling and when you're on
that comedy stage
i just want to go back to what we're
saying about comedy um
uh right now i do a storytelling show
and it's it's
it's going to work well with wrestling
fans and even the non-fans like it but
going out there on the stage and
trying comedy when you're new at it was
harrowing
in a way that you know wrestling
certainly was but even more so in the
sense that
when you're failing on stage you're very
exposed up there very
oh yeah it's really i remember going to
an event
i had given up on comedy because uh
it was just i wasn't enjoying it enough
i hadn't done it in six months and i was
asked to uh
if i would like to accompany the wounded
warriors to an event in new york city
back when i was living on long island
and it was an event at the gotham comedy
club
i said hey you know i used to do some
comedy if you want me to do a set just
let me know
but never told they never told me one
way or another so i'm sitting with the
warriors in the
first table off the stage and they said
hey we have somebody here who's gonna do
a guest set
former wwe champion mick foley and i
went up on stage without
a real set i just thought i could wing
it like it was a wrestling promo and i
started
dying such a miserable death on that
stage
and i was following people like judah
friedlander
yeah who are really really honed and
these people are doing
laser sharp seven minutes eight-minute
sets and uh
um yeah it was wow it was one really
great star
dan soder i think did a set and these
guys are really nailing it i go up there
trying to follow that and at one point i
just looked out of the crowd and i said
if i was in a pool i would ask for a
life preserver because i'm
dying up here i'm drowning up here and
people kind of
cheered when i got off stage judah
friedlander was a friend of mine
and he grabbed me or else i never would
have gone on stage again he goes
dude it wasn't i was a bro he doesn't
say bro he says dude
dude it's not as bad as you thought and
like come on jude it was awful he goes
hey dude dude like you've got something
other people don't have people actually
listen to you he said dude anyone else
goes on stage and doesn't get a laugh
for four full minutes they're done
he said but people listen to you dude
don't get me wrong you have to find a
way to make this stuff funny
and then he reaches in the back of his
jeans pocket he pulls out a stack of
index cards like this and he goes dude
if what i do on stage looks like it's
easy it's because i've worked really
hard to make it that way
he said i'll help you learn if you're
willing to put in the work
and so i started going to new york city
about two nights a week
for free and judo would drag me along to
five or six different clubs in a single
night
that's freaking newer comedy man you get
so many reps people get so
good because they'll do like half a
dozen shows the same night and they'll
try the same joke
and calibrate it and then they'll just
keep honing and honing it
like that that's the magic of new york
city comedy clubs
and the reps it's so important not only
in comedy but also when it comes to
doing those
uh promotional interviews in wrestling
and uh
i had the benefit of failing on much
smaller stages
both in comedy and in wrestling so that
when i did get to wcw
for a second run in 1991 and later in
wwe in
1996. i had a lot of right a lot of reps
yeah
and i believed in myself same thing
happened to me with
various tv news interviews where i was
running for president
and no one gave a [ __ ] circa 2018 but
you're kind of like fumbling in the dark
for a while and no one's really noticing
uh and then by the time you know you're
you're
uh on bigger stages you had enough reps
where
you know you're more comfortable because
like the first time you're not
comfortable at all
and then like the you know thousandth
time then it's like all right
you know but people just didn't see the
first 500 times
yeah yeah and some of the guys now might
know me is my son
my oldest son dewey is a writer for
wwe's nxt show
based out of orlando wow yeah yeah he
works his heart out there
uh in a lot of cases he's working with
these really seasoned
uh independent wrestlers who've never
given
promos so they've got the character down
as far as being
in ring but they are just kind of
grasping
and so my son has to write promos for
them that
sound like them that they can believe in
that they can invest in
and convince people is their own and
that's that's a difficult balancing act
wow look at this your son infusing life
into these uh up-and-coming wrestlers
that's actually kind of a beautiful
story uh i want to ask you a couple
questions you might not be able to talk
about this freely
um i i took issue with wwe's classifying
various people as independent
contractors
did i mention my son did i mention
andrew my son is employed
i always thought i was an employee when
i was there um
you know i i we questioned it uh
we seem to fit every aspect of being
here you've got a lot of freaking
control
of a lot of stuff that's going on they
do and there's some
but there was some loophole that allowed
wwe
um legally to be considered as
independent contractors so
you know i'm sometimes asked about
wrestlers union
and i and i talk to people who you know
on both sides
and the one thing that's part of this
and then
yeah oh wow that's like the kurt flood
of
you know mixed martial arts like she
really put everything she had on the
line
kurt floyd being the baby yeah leslie
great and she's taken a lot of
you know punishment online because of it
and so she's got
what an enormous heart and said same
heart and soul was on display when she
wanted to continue fighting despite her
hideous ear injury
is on display even more so because she's
willing to go out there and try to make
life better for the people uh who come
afterward
and uh you know i don't know the inner
workings of mixed martial arts like i do
uh wrestling so there seems to be an
issue that when guys are no longer
employed by
one of the big companies in order to do
the smaller shows they want to do
almost all of them would not be able to
create shows if they had to do it by
union standards it would be too
expensive to run
shows um and so i understand that side
of the argument
where i don't understand what i don't
understand is why we can't be considered
a part of the sag after umbrella because
on screen hours and hours a week yeah
that was like and i asked about it and
they said well
you know it's not like an actors union
where there are you know 10
000 actors you know who fit there's a
couple hundred wrestlers
uh who who would fall under that
umbrella and for what i'm told
it's not worth it for sag or after
sag slash after to fight for us because
there just aren't enough of us for it to
make it make sense if i'm wrong
and sag after is fighting for us i
apologize before i understand
we don't have the gravitas and it would
take four or five of the top
people in the entire business to stand
up and
uh i don't see that happening that's
very difficult for someone when they're
in that
kind of position to turn around and um
you know
fight for people who are might be
years after them uh you know or in
different situations but as you can tell
like i i
want to see uh performers um
treated uh more like the
folks in other industries when i was
leaving wwe in 2008 the talent didn't
know i was leaving but the
management did and i said can i just uh
can i address
you know the talent and they didn't know
what i was gonna say but they gave me
that opportunity
and i said and i was talking about
funding their own retirement
i said all wish we had a retirement plan
i said we do
we just have to fund it ourselves and i
said i know that a lot of you
in your 20s you think you're going to
live forever we don't do well
andrew like believing in our own
mortality because
i've said that if we did everything
according to a you know a risk-reward
analysis we wouldn't get in wrestling
because the risks are so high
the chance of making it are so small uh
and you know almost all of us get hurt
uh
physically and all of us get hurt
emotionally along the way it's
emotionally a very bruising ride
i said but you owe it to yourselves to
put some money and i told them about
this sep
ira you can fund your own plan if you're
lucky enough to hit upon
three or four big years in your mid-20s
you can really
lay a background and while it's nice to
think that you know
someone's going to come around and grant
us a retirement program
um that's not likely to happen and so i
urge them to get their
agenda to get uh thankfully the obama
you know
uh affordable care act went into uh a
motion and so people with pre-existing
conditions like myself
or even people who are younger who are
wrestlers who already have pre-existing
conditions
they can grab health insurance at a
young age and
keep it don't let it lapse fund your own
retirement you know as actively and
aggressively as you can
every year i put the maximum in there uh
and so when i was done i i asked
one of the guys came up gerald briscoe
and he said that's the most important
thing they'll hear
all week i said do you think any of them
will listen he said well if one does
that would be worth your time it does
change their life man yeah
someone's going to talk to you later and
say hey actually you know this is where
we
you know politics and the blend you know
the crossover
uh we're really big on hammering home
points
in wrestling the constant repetition of
single
catchphrases and uh this is
this is where i worry that maybe we
rubbed off on the former president in a
way that benefited him where he was like
wow
catch phrases let me trump is very very
wwe
you know yeah like yeah so i i said to
edge
we had the big match in 2006 a big
hardcore match
in the aftermath i told edge i said if
you and i both
independently of each other claim that
this was the greatest hardcore match in
history
within three weeks people will start to
believe it and they did
and that's great for us because we've
gone down in history now as having
one of the greatest hardcore matches in
history largely because we
advertised it and trumpeted it as such
but on a negative all you have to do is
say something for three weeks
repetitively
and a lot of the public will accept it
as fact no matter
how fictional it is and yeah i am
i do uh you know i i do mourn the fact
that that has been the case for a lot of
the country they just
pick up on you know just the constant
the constant catchphrases which i see
through in a heartbeat
but a lot of us in this country don't so
i think
the more it's said the more likely
people are to believe it no matter
you know whether it's the big lie or the
perfect letter you know you go back in
time and he
is like on a timetable in no collusion
you know for three months perfect letter
for two months uh
uh you know stop the steal now for six
works man yeah there's just some uh
human behavior
uh and the workings of our minds um
and wrestling takes advantage of in a
particular way politics does
comedy in a different way it's it's been
fun for me to try and
identify some of the overlaps uh you
know i mean i obviously i'm
more of a political figure uh how do you
feel about
the wrestling industry's future
because one of the things i i've picked
up on and you know i i obviously
grew up a huge fan and still have
friends in the industry
so the wwe's revenue now
flows through the streaming deal where
now they're folded into peacock
and the live gate doesn't seem as
important especially now because you
know it's just been out of like
one location for a while uh and the the
economics of the business seemed to have
changed very very fundamentally um
you do have aew you have tna which you
are the champion of as well
um and so you know i'm not sure how
uh healthy or unhealthy the industry
seems to people
like i i naturally root for aew
because i know some people over there um
but also because
an industry it feels healthier if you
have viable
oh sure yeah it sure does
i don't know the inner workings of wwe
and i know things have changed a lot
since we were dependent on the
pay-per-view numbers
and at that point it was a lot easier to
go to bat for yourself
armed with those numbers especially yeah
especially if you knew what one of your
colleagues
had received for a similar number and i
was not shy
about addressing what i thought were
financial
shortcomings on my checks to jim ross
when he was
at and to mr mcmahon
uh and on a lot of occasions i would
receive
something extra sometimes substantially
more uh but these days i don't you know
with the streaming
this is where i want to have no idea
what the basis for any argument would be
now
yeah i i would like to be able to go up
to wwe and say like hey man this billion
dollar
deal you hit on with peacock uh maybe i
should be
uh you know renumerated for that but i
don't know
well it's one of the things i said i
talked to chris jericho about this
because you look at these matches that
are part of the archives
you know like people sign up for the
streaming it's like how much are
charcoals matches worth on uh you know
on their archives like
is chris seeing any royalties from that
he's like well hell no to the second
question
[Laughter]
so then if you think about all the
performers yourself included
i mean if you think about all the
classic matches you were a part of
and how many people are watching those
uh and then what the
revenue share looks like because back in
the day when someone bought
like a mankind uh you know dollar
t-shirt like you might see a little bit
yeah
and i still do now streaming is that oh
good yeah streaming i don't know
i don't know it would be nice if uh the
company
factored us in to that equation i
believe that was a billion dollar deal
yeah and uh you know they've found a way
uh to stay ahead of the curve every step
of the way
and uh for a company to turn into their
most profitable year during the pandemic
is really
uh you know quite telling as to
what they do and they manage to keep a
show on every single week during the
pandemic without crowds and now they're
filtering in
and i guess they're going back out on
tour in july
so i really appreciate what they've
brought to uh the country in the world
as far as uh
keeping some sense of normalcy during
the pandemic but it would be it would
certainly be nice to factor in
some of those key players you know mr
mcmahon he gave about a dozen of us
stock options you know when the company
went public
and uh i noticed like when i go in to do
something for the company you know
they're there
are treating me really uh respectfully
as far as the financials from what i
received
and uh while it would be nice to uh be
part of that
revenue stream i'm doing i'm doing
pretty good
based uh not everybody's in that same
boat as i am
where they can uh you know continue to
have an income based on what they did
you know 20 years ago 25 years ago
but uh personally i'm doing pretty well
but i do think there should be some type
of uh
revenue sharing plan for everybody as
part of the peacock deal
um uh so you do seem like you've had an
incredible second and third
career fourth who's counting uh you know
you you're a parent
uh you know you you're alive which you
know
i mean i know a lot of the performers
you came up with uh are no longer with
us you seem remarkably
well adjusted um you know like at least
the scheme
um and you and i talked about how the
that we're both uh special needs parents
uh we both have
boys um on the autism spectrum
and you talk about why do you think that
you do seem so
happy wholesome well adjusted like in
the rest of it when so many people
and you talked about how uh pro
wrestling is an incredibly bruising
ride and career i mean it's physically
emotionally
uh it burns so many people out in a way
that
uh you know they don't come back from um
like i i'm
i'm curious why you think that you are
so
resilient and human um uh through it all
uh you know and whether there's anything
that someone can take from that
yeah well thank you for letting me speak
about this
i think that i have uh i'm in a
different situation than a lot of the
guys i always thought one of the most
difficult things in the world
would be to go from having your action
figure
on the rack next to spider-man and
superman and batman
one year and then be listing
professional wrestler on a job resume
the following year because for whatever
reason you know fans have continued to
support me
you know 20 years it's been 10 years
since my last match
uh nine years since i was in where i
rumbled but 21 years since i stopped
wrestling full time
and i went four years from 2000 to 2004
without a match and i did team up with
the rock at wrestlemania
made occasional comebacks at one point
too many comebacks and then hung it up
for good
nine years ago but fans have continued
to remember me and support me in a way
that they have not for
a lot of my peers and so i told mr
mcmahon i said and i even wrote this
in a later book i said the wwe is as
close to the land of oz
as any of us could get in a real life
setting you know where dorothy says some
of it was horrible
but most of it was wonderful and that's
the way i feel about wwe and i think
when people leave
they remember the parts they didn't like
and then as time goes by
they come to look at it as the best
times of their life
and i was always fortunate that i could
walk back and forth between those two
worlds so that
if i were to call them up today and say
hey i'd like to be on a house show
you know i'd like to make an appearance
i'd like to come backstage i'd like to
bring my children there'd be no problem
when they start doing shows
i called them up one time and i said hey
i'm doing an event in dublin ireland
uh the night after your house show you
know
would you mind if i showed up and i did
and they put me on the carton you know
put me on the card to make an appearance
and address people
and so i've always had that opportunity
and he events even said that this was my
playground and i could come back to play
anytime i wanted to so i've always loved
not only having the opportunity to come
back
anytime i want and be part of it but to
be recognized
um you know before the pandemic you know
on a daily basis
and then with uh uh the beauty of cameo
videos
and you know allow me to become those
characters to share stories with people
to put smiles on their faces and even
though i'm not seeing the instantaneous
feedback i get a message from somebody
and they say this is the best gift ever
because i put a lot of myself into it so
i'm lucky andrew in a way that
other guys are not so i can't speak to
what
they go through but i do know uh there's
a
major major withdrawal that comes with
leaving to be and then leaving wrestling
behind
yeah that makes sense like you you you
always have one foot in it
uh you know you always have things that
you can do and
because of your relationship with fans
and it sounds like wwe
then like it's not the same kind of
process that would occur to other
performers where
uh you know no longer on the shelf
you're no longer
employed and there there are so few uh
avenues for a pro wrestler
um you know there are only a few major
players are these indies
and the indies probably haven't even
been um open for the last number of
months
yeah yeah so that that makes sense mick
well you are
a legend you're someone that i'm so
thrilled uh
to be able to even spend this time with
uh and and you were
i think one of the biggest like human
success stories
i think in all of pro wrestling history
like that really i can't think of anyone
else who's
done what you've done who's had the
impact that you've had who's generated
the kind of love and affection and
loyalty that you have and you know the
fact that you can still
uh make people happy uh in ways big and
small
in person remotely like in any way it's
really just a testament to who you are
uh and i'm now i'm i'm thrilled to see
what's next for you
uh because you're still going it's
really awesome can i plug something
as we say oh please yeah oh
this uh video airs our interview airs
the day oh my gosh yes
the a e of a freaking biography of mick
foley he's getting the a
e treatment so you know you've made it
when you get
the the full biographical package yeah
it premiered i i i'm really excited
about it uh the director
and the crew and he hasn't even seen it
so he's gonna watch it at the same time
as you watch it for
20 minutes and i really loved it i'm
usually a harsh critic of my own
and the director and the whole crew they
were trading emails and they just said
that it was one of the most enjoyable
things they'd done and they really felt
like it was a great piece of television
and so it will probably echo some of the
sentiments you shared
first of all there were only eight of us
that got the treatment on a e
and it's so much more appreciated in
2021 than it was when they did
an initial one in 2001 partially because
it's 20 years after the fact i realize
how lucky i am and partially because
they're just doing a much better job on
these a
e's it's not the same narrator they had
eight different directors doing eight
different projects
all bringing their own vision to the
screen and again i'm up there with uh
you know my peers some of the biggest
stars ever
and to be chosen in that elite group is
really something special
and to know that people are going to
discover this who are not wrestling fans
because i think it is a really
yeah sure human story and then they can
appreciate it it's you know a young guy
uh you know living out his dream
pursuing his goals
you know and like i said in our
interview you know i'm lucky to have had
so many failures so that i can
appreciate those
successes well mick
i cannot wait to see the a e treatment
uh anyone listening to this
if you want to get the entire biography
uh and arc of mick go to a e and check
it out i'm sure they'll play it any
number of times
uh make such a fan and admirer and uh
even more so now
thank you so much my friend check it out
any
biography coming this week
[Music]
foreign